so do you think college is the only way
you can be successful in life
no matter what you do in life no matter
what dreams you chase if you have a
degree to fall back on you're always
safe financing college is very tough for
millions of americans tuition has gone
through the roof this is one of the most
important financial decisions in your
life that's a lot to put on an 18 year
old and yet we're saying do you want 50
000 in student loans i did look at it as
it was investing in myself like it's
okay i always thought everything's just
gonna be fine everything will sort
itself out
[Music]
the student loan problem has reached
epidemic proportions affecting
approximately 44 million americans
there's something about the word student
before the word loan that just makes us
think about this differently
and like differently in a very bad way
i had to do something i didn't have any
other options
i had taken out 125 thousand dollars
after four and a half years of college
we've brainwashed kids into thinking
this is normal this is safe except it's
not
there is no one that's going to stop you
from borrowing yeah like when you want
something really bad you got to take all
of it everyone has that
everyone has it there's a whole lot of
people who view your ability to take on
a ton of debt as their chance to get
rich you know here i am 36
i have a million dollars in student
loans
student loan borrowers have less rights
less protections and we use the full
weight of the government to make sure
you pay that back i know people that are
planning to die with that debt is that
the american dream
the choices that they made now own them
we would never get a house we wouldn't
be able to have kids
i'm paying all these bills and i have
nothing
we've officially hit rock bottom
if i can meet a complete stranger and
this is what we have in common that's an
issue i do not want to live my life
paying for things in my past that's the
normal i refuse to be a part of people
shouldn't leave college in chains
stop telling people that this is the
path
you